لذا فهذه
صفعة في منتصف الموقع عند خروجك من
المترو ، نعم ، ستمشي باتجاه
المركز حيث
سنقيم قبتنا وهذا هو المكان الذي سنحصل فيه
على المباني الثلاثة الرئيسية التي
تأخذها إما  يسارًا نحو الفرصة
للأمام مباشرة لتحقيق الاستدامة أو اتخاذ الحق
في التنقل
بشكل جيد ، هكذا يبدو هذا الموقع نفسه
اليوم بعد أقل من أربع سنوات ،
إنه قرية ، إنها مدينة بأكملها
وهي المنظر الذي تنظر إليه هناك
من الحديقة  في السماء التي
تقدم بانوراما لما أطلقت عليه ريما
هاشمي مدينة المستقبل ،
حيث التقيت أنا وهي لإجراء مقابلة متابعة
اليوم ،
أعتقد أننا قدمنا ما ال
زمنا بفعله وتمكنا من العمل جن
ًا إلى جنب مع 192 دو
ة  حقًا تجمع العالم معًا في
وقت ميمون جدًا
بهذا المعنى ، والأهم
من ذلك ، أليس كذلك لأن
ما كان يمكن أن يكون مجرد معرض
كبير وكبير كل ما أصبح شيئًا
أكثر أهمية ، هناك بالتأكيد
رمز للسير البشري  فكرة التواصل
مع بعضنا البعض في لحظة صعبة
ولكن أيضًا إدراك أنه فقط من
خلال التعاون من
خلال اتصال قوي من خلال
مشاركة أفضل الممارسات في المعرفة
بالمعلومات يمكننا التغلب على
بعض هذه التحديات العالمية
يجب أن يكون
هناك خيبة أمل طبيعية
لأن  عدد الأشخاص
لن يكون كما كان يمكن أن يكون في
الواقع لا
لا
لا أعتقد أن
ثلاثة أشهر في منتصف هذا
الوباء
ليأتي تسعة ملايين تسعة ملايين شخص من
خلال
تسعة ملايين زيارة في بلد
لا يتجاوز عدد سكانه 10 ملايين
نسمة وقوي وطني  أمر
رائع الآن ، ما زلنا
نستعد لتحقيق
أهداف أفضل أهداف أقوى ،
تجارب ذات مغزى أكبر للناس ، لكن
هذا أمر مثير ومميز
أيضًا لأولئك الذين يأتون من خلاله ، إنه أمر
رائع
تمامًا ، ما الذي ستفعله
به جميعًا عند الانتهاء.  يعني أن
دبي هناك والمطار
هناك وماذا ستفعل
بكل هذا  عند الانتهاء ووجود أبو
ظبي هناك ، فهذه
أخت صغيرة طبيعية إذا كنت ستفعل ذلك في كل من
دبي وأبو ظبي ، فهي بنية تحتية
لا تصدق بتقنية 5G مزودة بتقنية قوية للغاية ،
كل شيء قمنا ببنائه سيبقى
لدينا العديد من الأجنحة
القطرية  ابقَ أيضًا لدينا المؤتمر
والمعرض هناك
وستحصل على مترو دبي على طول
الطريق لذا
فهو حقًا مركز للتكنولوجيا الجديدة مركز لابتكار جديد
والخطط موجودة بالفعل لإطلاق
هذا بعد 80 يومًا  عندما أغلقنا ،
هل سبق لك أن شككت في أنه
سيفتح الوباء يصيب الجميع
بقوة عندما اضطررنا للتأجيل لمدة عام ،
أعتقد أنها كانت لحظة مهمة
لنا جميعًا
عندما أقول لنا إنني أعني حقًا
المجتمع الدولي ولكن أيضًا
حكومة  الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، كيف نكون
مضيفين مسؤولين ، كيف تجمع
العالم كله معًا بينما لا تزال
في منتصف هذا ،
أعتقد أن هناك شخصًا تعرفه ، هناك
خفة الحركة ، هناك وضوح في الرؤية ،
هناك علم  النهج القائم على
الأساس الثاني أعتقد أنه مع مرض كوفيد يجب أن يكون الشخص
ريتشارد متواضعًا حقًا ، فلا يمكنك المضي قدمًا في
نفسك ، فأنت بحاجة إلى الاستمرار في
متابعته يومًا بعد يوم
ومعرفة المزيد والمزيد عن ذلك
بالتشاور مع الخبراء وعدم
أخذ أي شيء كأمر مسلم به  ليس أقلها
التجربة المذهلة التي
يقدمها هذا المكان ،
دعني أسألك ما الذي تعلمته عن
نفسك
لأنه عندما التقينا آخر مرة
سألتك ، نعم طلبت منك أن أتذكرها ، نعم
الآن مع كوفيد واضطررت إلى التأخير
والأزمة ما رأيك
هل قمت بتغيير ما تعلمته عن
نفسك وقدراتك ونقاط قوتك
ونقاط ضعفك أعتقد أننا جميعًا
كبرنا جميعًا ، أعني فريقي بالتأكيد
أنا واحد
منهم وأعتقد أن
المنظور له شعور قوي حقًا  من
منظور المرونة ، أنت تعلم أن بعضًا منا يمكنه
التعامل مع الضغط الذي
لا يستطيع البعض منا القيام به وهذا ليس سيئًا أو جيدًا ، إنها
فقط الطريقة التي يتكون بها دستورنا ،
أعتقد من وجهة
نظري بالتأكيد أن فريقي قادر
كانت هذه رحلة تعلمنا فيها
عن أنفسنا أكثر مما تعلمناه عن
الحدث الفعلي
ومسؤولية الاستضافة هل فاجأت نفسك
نعم كانت هناك لحظات عديدة
اعتقدت فيها أن
هذا صعب حقًا
ثم تلتقط نفسك وتعتمد
على  فريق وأنت تعتمد على
قيادتك ،
الذين كانوا دائمًا معنا في كل
خطوة على الطريق ،
أعتقد أن قناعتهم بنا ، أنت
تعرف ما الذي يمنحه لنا الزوار الذين يأتون من
خلاله القوة التي يأتون إليها ،
فهم متحمسون لاستكشافهم
إنهم يقضون وقتًا رائعًا وهم
مسؤولون وأعتقد أننا استمدنا الكثير
من القوة بالإضافة إلى الفريق الذي
تمكنت من إخراج هذا منك من الفريق
الذي تمكنا من إدارته ،
فماذا ستفعل بعد ذلك؟
خذ استراحة لطيفة وسأستمر
في خدمة أمتي وحكومتي وعائلتي.
لقد جئت من مجموعة
من الرجال والنساء الذين
يستمتعون فقط بكونهم في خدمة الآخرين ،
لذلك سأستمر في القيام بذلك.
علاقات قابلة لإعادة الاستخدام مع
البلدان الموجودة هنا ، أرغب في زيارة
بعضها بشكل حقيقي
واستكشاف وتعلم المزيد ، آمل أن أستمر في النمو
ومواصلة تقديم
قيمة لنا كإماراتيين وكإمارات العربية المتحدة ولكن
أيضًا لما تعنيه التعددية
وماذا يعني التعاون الدولي
بصراحة ، لا أستطيع أن أفكر حتى الآن ، أعتقد أنني سألتك
أيضًا عما إذا كان لديك ليال بلا نوم
سواء كان هذا جيدًا أم لا ،
نعم ، ما زلت أعاني من ليالي بلا نوم ،
ما زلت أقابل العديد من الليالي بلا نوم.
بعد
80 يومًا من إجراء المقابلات معي بعد انتهائها ،
لكن انظر مرة أخرى ،
لا نأخذ أي شيء كأمر مسلم به ، فنحن
متواضعون في مواجهة ما قد
يحدث
، ونحترم
كل
لحظة نتمتع فيها
بامتياز كوننا مضيفًا